i think
look let me let me pull up the story and
get your thoughts on it this is uh abc7
nearly half of democrats say fines and
prison time appropriate for questioning
vaccines just questioning them they also
said there's i believe 45 would in turn
uh uh the unvaccinated meaning they
would take you to a designated isolated
facility
i think 59 were in favor of house arrest
so when you see the alignment of the new
york times when you see the media
when you see it there are this many
people in this country who are willing
to outright just arrest someone for
speaking out against them
it kind of sounds like it's beyond just
the media there's there's something
deeply
rotten expanding or growing within the
core of of the american side it's a core
value it's it's it's a
the primary value of of american society
which
part of the american founding i mean
this goes back to you know
cicero you have to have information to
make informed decisions and that's the
whole that's why the first amendment's
first it's a cliche i i question whether
half of democrats actually believe that
i think that's probably i q i'm
skeptical about the amount of people the
media is telling you actually what was
the actual question on the on the poll i
suppose that would be a good one to pull
away from this we could definitely look
that up but i think the scarier aspect
here is that a lot of these things that
some of these democrats are calling for
are policies that are implemented
already in other parts of the world and
democrats and other establishment
statists want to implement here in the
united states 29 according to this
rasmussen poll of democrats supported
taking children away from people if they
refuse to take the vaccine that's a
policy that has already been instituted
in some places in canada when we talking
about when we're talking about detaining
people that's happening in austria and
australia and in other parts around the
world already so we have to understand
that this slippery slope to dystopian
total totalitarian nightmare craphole
society is
very close to happening because of this
kind of echo chamber delusional thinking
that's being perversed by the corporate
media so what i see happening is that
there are very evil people like james
mentioned earlier it's a battle between
good and evil who know full well what
they're doing what their plans are they
want to lock you up they want to take
away your rights and they're lying about
you on perfect on purpose gleefully
willfully and we're having a fairness
battle i don't think that they're going
to win i'm actually quite hopeful
everyone's cynical
and it pisses me off i mean
i talk about this too in this book a
chapter called propaganda
consent must be informed not
manufactured all serious theories of
democracy were republic which is also a
democracy including the economic theory
hinge on the notion that voters have
reliable access to information i think
technology allows us to do that again
let me remind your audience
i am banned on twitter
i my organization is banned on twitter
and our story was the number one
trending story in the world why
because of the information that we
released
documents inside the department of
defense
darpa a marine corps major fellow at the
department of defense wrote about this
covet and wrote about the fact that
it was too risky for the department of
defense to approve
what was going on and that story it was
about the strength of the information
and i believe that human nature is such
that if people are able to see it for
themselves
firsthand participant journalism not
second-hand anonymous sources i think
we're going to prevent society's
collapse by continuing to do that
journalism i agree i think it's working
we i mentioned this with you know cnn
and msnbc having a ratings collapse
getting back uh uh to the to the the
darkness of this when we see this paul
from smu museum i do think it's fair to
point out that maybe maybe it's a bad
poll from rest music maybe the questions
aren't right but who knows but i will
say this
kamala harris
was raising money through twitter to
bail out rioters
you know uh in 2020 some of the most
extreme rights i've ever seen when i
talk to people i came from minneapolis
yes
but but not only that but i mean the
riots were across the country so when we
when we're seeing some of the worst
riots we've seen in 50 years maybe and i
talk to people about the potential for
civil conflict civil unrest or whatever
and they say oh it's not that bad it's
because we're frogs in a pot that are
boiling
when andy you report on this stuff you
you expose who these violent extremists
are
the media lies about you all of these
different institutions lie about you
they make things up it there there is
there is i don't know how you describe
it i call it a cult
they're they are in they're in line with
each other but it's not like they
actively collude at a national level
where like a message goes out and say
everyone say andy knows you know wrong
they just all do it
yeah i
i was quite naive and in 2019 before i
became more of a a well-known figure and
i was just regional person in the
pacific northwest
after my uh assault uh in the summer of
2019 that
punches kicks in the the milkshakes the
hospitalization for the traumatic brain
injury um
i
was naive enough at the time that i
thought the media organizations would be
out to support me i remember jake tapper
i believe was one of the very few
center-left journalists who
issued a tweet that condemned what
happened to me and i really appreciated
that and he got
so much blood
that he ended up deleting that
and then all the hit pieces came out
in a way that seemed sort of coordinated
and in james who speaks to this and i
was watching kind of in real time with
in fascination at how they can destroy
someone's reputation so
uh
there was initial outpouring support for
me so then what happened was a local
blog in portland interviewed somebody
and gave this person a pseudonym so i
have no idea who this person is who
accused me of uh being in collaboration
with this far-right group in portland so
one i couldn't i couldn't confront my
accuser
uh legally i couldn't do anything either
we don't even know the identity of this
person so we can't even write a cease
and desist about her and then this
damning
story and headline which is false from
the book that was published in portland
mercury they never reached out to me for
a comment by the way it was then
repeated in other publications like
uh
slay and box etc etc and then that is
cited in your in your wikipedia and then
when somebody googles you who doesn't
know who you are that's the first thing
they see
and that is your reputation i i wonder
how long it's gonna last though you know
they go after joe rogan the most popular
podcast in the world and the stupidest
thing you can do is lie about joe
because the 11 million people on average
who watch his show the 50 million who've
seen some of his biggest shows the
people who are fans of mma and know him
or who just watch his netflix stand up
they see this story and they go yeah
that's not true
and all of a sudden you lie about
someone as popular as joe and people
start waking up and now we're starting
to see it we're seeing a major shift
this uh poll came out gallup released
this one of the most credible polling
institutions that as of the fourth
quarter of 2021
more people identify as republican or
republican leaning than democrat for the
first time since i believe it was 1991.
there actually may have been a period
around the 2000s where it was fairly
even between the two but this is a gap
now five points right i'm not saying
republicans are the right answer or that
you know democrats are always the wrong
answer but regular people are looking at
the establishment they're associating it
with one side of the political spectrum
and saying i don't have anything to do
with well it's not just joe it's joe
also influencing people like dana white
influencing people like aaron rodgers
that are going out there and speaking
these larger truths and some people
would say breaking the mass
psychosis the mass formation psychosis
that of course the corporate media in
unison tells us doesn't exist as of
course the financial times literally
calls for psyops as of course even the
canadian joint operations command even
admittedly said that they have relied on
propaga propaganda techniques used in
afghanistan with kovid because they saw
it as a unique opportunity to test out
their propaganda techniques on the
general public you know what you were
saying about uh joe rogan that's why
they try and silence him that's why
these
doctors and researchers and scientists
came out to try and not fair to call
them that what not fair to call on the
doctors anymore
like a campus farmer on it
a campus farm
it was less than 100 medical doctor some
of them not even practice did they have
like a dentist okay so the the the
letter written by a bunch of hacks who a
few of whom claim to be doctors
apparently um you know they're going
after joe rogan they're going after all
of these people because they don't uh
they don't understand that the american
people can
see lies that they can see you know
these falsehoods that are being uh
forced upon them and you know americans
go after the truth that's one of my
things but i think i want to go back to
it characteristics was saying because
you're you're talking to a man here who
has effectively suffered i think that's
fair to say it's some form or another
this is traumatic i will speak
personally i i suffered a kind of a form
of ptsd after my new orleans
incarceration
and i was reminded of that
after the fbi raid at least for a day or
two i did and people say are you scared
well of course you're human
i mean i i've pretty much
removed
most of my desire to be liked by these
people i'm almost down to completely
zero i'm never going to be fully zero
because i'd be a sociopath if i was zero
but i just want to talk a little about
that for a minute because it's a theme
that i think is very important to
discuss here because it is a
prerequisite
for
being effective
you know i wrote about this that that
this is an age where the loss of one's
twitter account is treated like the loss
of one's life
imagine if everyone watching this did
not care if they took away the twitter
account what impact could they have on
you your reputation what does that mean
your wikipedia page taking away
de-platforming you
the moment you stop worrying about that
and you don't let that handcuff you pun
intended is the moment you're actually
able to actually be free to do the
things and do the journalism and i know
what it's like i articulate this in
words better than i can off the cuff
no one can deprive me of my reputation
or andy of your reputation
they've already been deprived we've
already been deprived of that by by
declarations from credible journalists
that's not incredible journalists how
are these journalists credible they're
credible by virtue of the decree that
they are indeed credible because they
say so
and to see that happen it's traumatizing
it can make an otherwise confident man
question your own perception of reality
in the beginning it did in the beginning
of my journey i questioned my own
perception of reality
and but once you get through that and
get through the other side of it which i
think you have
i think any any survivor of that sort of
abuse develops superpowers
like you're you're a stronger man than
you were you're a better journalist than
you were and you're wiser than you were
and what i've learned is the moment you
i've said this to you before thank you
cliche
the moment you really stop caring about
what wikipedia thinks of you and what
jack dorsey thinks of you they've
already taken away our twitter accounts
eric lost his this week we have no more
twitter accounts we're still training on
twitter jack's gone for all you know he
actually likes what frank jack is a
metaname for whoever the ceo is
but the moment you stop giving a [ __ ]
about what they think about you is the
moment you're free oh yeah it was it was
a magic moment i remember uh during
occupy wall street i got a big surge of
followers on twitter and with that a big
surge of people saying really mean
things to me and it was the first time
i'd ever experienced a wave of hundreds
and thousands hundreds to thousands of
people just saying the nastiest fake
things about me and for a minute i kind
of freaked out i was like what does this
mean for me what is this going to be
what is it what is it going to do am i
going to be able to keep doing this am i
going to be able to work and then went
to bed and woke up
made some food had some bacon
watched some tv and then i was like
nothing's happening it gives you tough
skin but nothing happened and then and
then it hurts a lot of things it does
it's true but i'm just like i'm living
my life like normal and after a little
while i was like i just figured
something out i can turn off the
notifications
and then it doesn't exist anymore yeah
and there we are now i just don't have
notifications turned on why listen to
these people and being offended is a
choice people need to understand that if
someone is attacking you if you're
giving them power in that by reacting to
it you're you're playing into their
games and i think a lot of us in this
room have dealt with a lot of crazy
stuff me and tim had to deal with the
police raid as well of you know guns in
the face everything you know i was
arrested i was beat up andy you were
beat up and tim you were jumped i i
think you know james you went through
your stuff and then the the amount of
craziness that we have to deal with we
have to understand it is nothing new
this is something that of course the the
the people who don't like the bigger
truths exposed usually those are the
techniques they use against effective
people exposing them look what happened
to mlk look how the fbi treated him the
fbi literally spied on him they got
tapes of him they sent him letters
trying to get him to commit suicide and
this is the federal bureau of
investigations decades ago going after
people who are changing society and i
would argue that the world is round
and that catches up with the bad guys
yes they did all those things to him and
it is martin luther king day but as
martin luther king said the arc of the
moral universe bends
long but it bends towards justice so the
bad guys don't get i've seen in my life
these bad guys it always catches up to
them yeah they get away with it for a
little while
but right you know look thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm now
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you